mes chers amis cette première campagne
du budget d'initiative citoyenne
arrive à son terme nous l'avons lancé
vous avez participé et je tiens à
remercier toutes celles et ceux qui ont
avec le département répondu présent à
cette première campagne près de 120
dossiers reçus et bien évidemment
des dossiers de qualité où on voit bien
que tout le monde l'a fait l'effort
d'aller chercher de répondre à ce souci
de mettre l'humain au cœur des projets
je salue donc la qualité de votre
travail peut aller vers l'humain va
aussi la transition écologique vers à
mieux être dans la société d'aujourd'hui
nous arrivons
à la fin c'est atteint malheureusement
ne seront pas retenus mais il y aura de
nouvelles campagnes vous pourrez
approfondir ces dossiers et pour les
autres qui auront réussi
brillamment a passé le cap de cette
première campagne vous pouvez bien
évidemment compter sur le soutien du
Département pour vous accompagner le
grand joie est arrivé donc invite de
toute à faire comme moi
allons regarder les résultats sur le
site big budget d'initiative citoyenne
du département
[Musique]